in australia it's it's much worse than
that it's much sadder than that
four newborn babies just died in
australia
because of the covet restrictions so
four newborn babies in adelaide
needed heart surgery when they were born
a great number of newborns who need
heart surgery
and
thanks to modern medicine they can get
it taken care of
but
they were not able to get it taken care
of because in adelaide they did not have
the resources to perform the heart
surgery and they could not be
transferred interstate because of travel
restrictions that are keeping people
locked in their homes
so in order
to prevent
people from getting the cough
in order to prove it because there were
one or two cases in australia and
because of that they lock down
everything
we're not even talking about
lots of deaths or even lots of
hospitalizations just you know some
cases
of the virus that doesn't pose a grave
threat to most people four newborn cute
little babies
died
and their parents are gonna have to deal
with that for the rest of their lives
and a cute little baby whom they carried
for nine months cute little helpless
vulnerable baby
was sacrificed on the altar of neurotic
public health fears over a cough over
over something that for most people
feels like a bad flu actually for a lot
of people it doesn't even feel as bad as
the flu
that's that's bad stuff
that's
that's not not a good situation
for anybody
if it only saves one life it's worth it
that's what andrew cuomo told us during
the covet locked if it only saves one
life and this is this is the fear forget
even a second about the virus itself
forget even just dunking on democrats or
republicans or left or right
this is what happens when society
loses its sense of balance its sense of
of the broader picture when it misses
the forest for the trees during even the
trump coronavirus briefings the only
people who would speak were fouchy and
dr scarf
what about the military we didn't hear
what about the economics advisors we
didn't hear what about it was it was
almost exclusively fouchy and dr scarf
they focused only on public health and
the rest of the country went to pot
that's going on around the world as well
and we still haven't learned our lesson
hey there before you go
if you liked this video please leave me
a comment just a little hey michael like
this
hey michael nice hair hey buddy cool
sweater just whatever you want you can
also subscribe to michael knowles showed
apple podcast but if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your
podcast head on over to it right now
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]